[Música]
sabíais que francia es el país con la
zona económica exclusiva marítima más
grande de todo el mundo fijaos por
ejemplo en este mapa
hablamos ni más ni menos que de 11
millones 691 mil kilómetros cuadrados de
mar en los que francia tiene la plena
exclusividad para por ejemplo explotar
sus recursos pesqueros minerales o
energéticos unas aguas en las que en
definitiva puede hacer lo que le dé la
gana y no sé no me digáis que nos
resulta sorprendente que un país como
francia sea el país con más aguas
explotables de todo el mundo si por
ejemplo comparásemos el tamaño de estas
aguas con un país podríamos decir que
son más grandes que los eeuu y 18 veces
el tamaño de la propia francia terrestre
por supuesto más del 96% de toda esta
zona económica exclusiva repartida a lo
largo y ancho de todo el mundo se
encuentra fuera del territorio
continental europeo que todos
identificamos como la franja no os
parece curioso sorprendente claro que la
pregunta que todos podemos hacernos es
de dónde procede semejante dominio
marítimo pues bien creo que no es ningún
secreto que francia tiene un enorme
intenso pasado colonial un pasado
gracias al cual aún hoy conserva
territorios repartidos por todo el globo
terráqueo
[Música]
américa áfrica la antártida oceanía
salvo en asia los franceses tienen
territorios en todos los continentes del
planeta y como cada territorio costero
tiene derecho a unas 200 millas mar
adentro de zona económica exclusiva el
resultado es el que acabamos de ver
estos territorios de ultramar son por
así decirlo enclaves estratégicos que le
otorgan a la república francesa una gran
proyección internacional
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no olvidemos que además del tema de las
zonas económicas exclusivas estos
territorios de ultramar también son
estratégicos por muchas otras cuestiones
digamos que estos lugares le permiten a
francia extender su actividad militar
por todo el mundo y también refuerzan su
influencia geopolítica por ejemplo hacen
que sea la única potencia europea con
territorios en el indo pacífico son por
así decirlo la clave de que francia sea
el tercer país con mayor huella militar
en todo el mundo tan solo tras eeuu y
rusia otro buen ejemplo lo tenemos en
cubo en la guayana francesa donde se
encuentra el puerto espacial de la esa y
la nasa europea para entendernos y que
es de donde se lanzan todos los cohetes
espaciales de la agencia europea
[Música]
claro que llegados a este punto hay unas
cuantas preguntas que podemos hacernos
hasta qué punto estos territorios forman
parte de francia tienen un nivel de vida
similar están acaso contentos con seguir
formando parte de la república francesa
como los trata parís queridos amigos
amigas en este vídeo intentaremos
conocer un poquito mejor la cara más
desconocida de francia para ello
echaremos un vistazo a cuatro de sus
territorios de ultramar más importantes
para entendernos esto es lo que resta
del antiguo imperio francés al atentos
libertad igualdad fraternidad
si alguno pensaba que el lema oficial de
la república francesa se cumple a
rajatabla siento deciros que está
bastante equivocado al menos en lo que
tiene que ver con la gavi de la igualdad
si reparamos en los casi tres millones
de franceses que no viven en la francia
metropolitana de la vieja europa sino a
miles de kilómetros de distancia unos
franceses que en muchos casos están
empezando a enfadarse bastante con la
situación y razones no les faltan pero
antes de entrar en eso un pequeño
paréntesis habéis oído hablar de nuestro
boletín semanal exclusivo para patronos
habéis oído hablar de los productos
exclusivos de visual político que no
están a la venta en ningún otro sitio
queréis recibir vídeos exclusivos
periódicamente pues amigos amigas si os
gusta lo que hacemos y queréis ayudarnos
a seguir creciendo y mejorando podéis
encontrar todo esto y más en la
comunidad de patrimonio visual político
os dejamos por aquí abajo el enlace en
la descripción y un millón de gracias a
todos los que formáis parte del patrón
de visual político pero dicho esto
sigamos con el tema que hoy nos ocupa
empecemos si os parece mirando en el
bolsillo porque si algo caracteriza los
territorios franceses de ultramar son
precisamente sus pobres condiciones
socioeconómicas
[Música]
en la francia de ultramar las tasas de
pobreza son mucho más elevadas que en la
metrópoli por ejemplo si en la francia
europea el porcentaje de la población
por debajo del umbral de la pobreza
ronda el 15% en el resto de territorios
de la república la cifra se dispara por
ejemplo en mayo la tasa de pobreza se
sitúa en el 77 3% en la guayana francesa
en el 52,9 en guadalupe en el 30 y 45 en
martinica en el 28,6
pero como esto de las tasas de pobreza
es algo bastante relativo qué ocurre si
nos fijamos por ejemplo en el pei de per
cápita también hay diferencias pues lo
cierto es que si para que os hagáis una
idea el territorio francés de ultramar
más rico reunión tiene un pib per cápita
de unos 25 mil dólares mientras que el
departamento más pobre de la francia
metropolitana tiene unos 31.500 es decir
un 26% más para colmo estos lugares
situados allende los mares son muy
dependientes de los euros que emanan del
presupuesto público de francia y más
recientemente también de los fondos de
la unión europea
[Música]
una situación que tiene mucho pero que
mucho que ver con la falta de libertades
económicas y de descentralización que
sufren estos territorios porque a
diferencia de londres que históricamente
ha dado plena libertad a sus territorios
de ultramar parís ha transitado un
camino muy diferente no sé no parece
tener mucho sentido que el grueso de las
leyes incluida la legislación tributaria
las normas comerciales y gran parte de
las regulaciones de francia se apliquen
en lugares tan remotos tan diferentes y
en algunos casos tan pobres como los
territorios de ultramar sí es cierto que
en el año 2000 se llevó a cabo una
pequeña descentralización que hace que
algunos de esos territorios cuenten con
algunas normas y leyes ligeramente
diferentes a la metrópoli y también que
cuenten con algún incentivo fiscal pero
el mil por asomo eso ha sido suficiente
y si en algunos casos como el de nueva
caledonia cuentan incluso con sus
propias cámaras legislativas pero amigos
amigas algo excepciones al final todo
absolutamente todo termina pasando por
parís algo que viene bastante de lejos
[Música]
y de hecho estos territorios también
tienen un grado de integración comercial
muy bajo con cualquier cosa que no sea
francia una situación heredada del
principio de exclusividad que prohibía a
las colonias francesas cualquier
relación comercial con países
extranjeros dejando con ello la
metrópolis pues su monopolio comercial
con sus colonias luego su atraso
económico también está muy relacionado
con su pasado esclavista el cual dio
lugar a que la economía de estos lugares
sí pero especializada en actividades de
bajo valor añadido como la producción de
caña plátano algodón o cacao pero amigos
la economía no es la única brecha entre
franceses que nos vamos a encontrar
hablamos de importantes diferencias
políticas y sociales que en algunos
casos incluso están amenazando la propia
soberanía de francia atentos
[Música]
nueva caledonia dependencia a la vista
[Aplausos]
nueva caledonia es un territorio francés
situado en un archipiélago de decenas de
islas en esa maravillosa región conocida
como pacífico sur junto con la polinesia
francesa son los dos territorios con más
autonomía y los dos únicos catalogados
por la onu como territorios autónomos
territorios que de alguna u otra forma
están pendientes de ser descolonizados
es decir que están pendientes de decidir
en un referéndum si optan por la
independencia o por mantenerse dentro de
francia con un cierto grado de
autogobierno pues bien el caso de nueva
caledonia es especial en 1998 se cerró
el acuerdo del umea por el que se
transferían ciertas competencias de
gobierno francés a este departamento y
también se acordó la celebración de
varios referendos de independencia que
tuvieron lugar en 2018 o 2020 y 2021
referéndum son los que por cierto la
abrumadora mayoría votó a favor de
seguir perteneciendo a francia claro que
la realidad es que en estos referéndum
hubo mucha tela que cortar una buena
parte de los neo caledonias que están a
favor de independizarse de francia no
participaron en esos referéndum para
intentar boicotear los y deslegitimar
los mediante quórum muy pero que muy
bajos el movimiento pro independencia de
nueva caledonia rechaza la legitimidad
del voto al no de esta forma en él
referéndum celebrado el 2021 el día de
independencia ganó con el 96 5% de los
votos eso sí la participación pues fue
de apenas el 44 por ciento es decir que
bien podríamos pensar que
aproximadamente la otra mitad de la
población no está a favor de seguir
formando parte de francia y seguramente
la explicación de semejante descontento
tenga mucho pero que mucho que ver con
la sensación de ser ciudadanos de
tercera y no tener la capacidad de
cambiar nada
el pedazo más pobre de francia
nueva caledonia no es el único
territorio de ultramar francés que se
siente en cierto modo marginado por la
metrópoli también tenemos el caso de
mayor una isla francesa nueve veces más
pequeña que mallorca que está enclavada
entre madagascar y mozambique y que es
con diferencia el territorio francés más
pobre de todos mayor fue la única de las
cuatro islas comoras que en 1974 votaron
a favor de seguir perteneciendo a
francia mientras que las otras tres
formaron un estado independiente al que
por cierto pues tampoco le ha ido nada
bien
[Música]
a pesar de formar parte de francia y de
contar con espectaculares paisajes aguas
cristalinas de color turquesa y
frondosas y verdes montañas que hacen
las delicias de los turistas en mayor
una buena parte de la población vive
poco menos que en infraviviendas y una
gran cantidad de calles por no tener no
tienen ni asfalto pese a ello su
situación es considerablemente mejor que
en las islas comoras desde donde procede
una gran cantidad de inmigrantes la idea
de ser parte de francia y de la unión
europea ha traído a muchos comorenses a
mayor hasta el punto de que a día de hoy
sólo el 45 por ciento de los maillots en
ses han nacido en la isla y el 70% de
los niños nacidos en mamuts su capital
lo hicieron de madres extranjeras
y a los problemas económicos y la falta
de oportunidades se le suman problemas
sociales de todo tipo entre los que se
incluye también una creciente
inseguridad lo que explica noticias como
esta disturbios en mayo los residentes
de la isla francesa acorralan a los
extranjeros un grupo de residentes de la
isla francesa de mayotté en el océano
índico ha estado reuniendo a presuntos
inmigrantes ilegales y llevándolos ante
la policía local por supuesto todo esto
políticamente termina traduciéndose en
titulares como éste
marie le pen a la cabeza en mayor gran
avance para jean luc mélenchon y voto de
castigo contra emmanuel macrón chick
puede que sorprenda pero los territorios
africanos de francia gana el pp y la
pregunta es qué hace el elíseo para
intentar cambiar las cosas pues
básicamente nada de nada excepto la
vieja fórmula de soltar más y más dinero
lo que lejos de alimentar el desarrollo
ha hecho que esta isla al igual que lo
que ocurre con el resto de territorios
tengan una dependencia brutal de la
metrópoli lo que ha hecho de ellos
lugares rentistas de parís para que os
hagáis una idea sin las subvenciones de
francia y muchos de estos territorios no
podría ni siquiera satisfacer sus
necesidades más básicas y esto es una
cuestión de modelo si por un lado tienes
que cumplir con toda la farragosa
burocracia y las interminables
regulaciones de francia que hacen
difícil tener empresas competitivas y
por la otra reagan de dinero para
financiar todo tipo de servicios
sociales qué es lo que vas a hacer pues
es una cuestión de incentivos te
especializas en intentar que te lleguen
más y más dinero te vuelves rentista del
presupuesto público pero amigos amigas
visto el caso de mayor sigamos
[Música]
a francia caribeña
desde la isla de mayor podemos cruzar
medio mundo y volver a aterrizar en
francia concretamente en las islas
caribeñas de guadalupe martinica san
bartolomé y san martín de todas ellas
los guadalupeños y los martiniqueños son
quizás los menos satisfechos con su
estatus una buena parte de su población
se siente muy discriminada por parís o
un ejemplo pues tenemos el caso de un
pesticida si un pesticida que causó todo
un revuelo en guadalupe y martinica hace
ya algunos años
la flor de kona es un pesticida que era
ampliamente utilizado en plantaciones de
plátano el problema con él es que era
tóxico hasta que digamos todo normal
cosas por el estilo han pasado en todas
partes lo que no es tan normal es que
francia a aprobarse su uso en guadalupe
dos años después de que en 1979 la o ms
lo declarase
potencialmente cancerígeno tampoco
parece tan normal que un tiempo después
se descubriera que una investigación
parlamentaria en la vecina isla de
martinica donde también se empleó este
pesticida determinó que francia estaba
al tanto de la toxicidad de este ki
mismo desde 1969 aún así 9 y estos
territorios de ultramar lo emplearán
intensamente
[Música]
evidentemente este tipo de cosas no
contribuyen mucho a crear una sensación
de pertenencia a la nación francesa y en
este caso la percepción más extendida
entre los lugareños es que sus vidas por
decirlo de alguna forma les importa un
rábano a los burócratas de parís
claro que esta percepción también viene
de muy lejos porque es algo muy pero que
muy enraizado en la cosmovisión local es
su pasado esclavista y lo que ocurrió
con la abolición de la esclavitud porque
amigos amigas cuando se abolió la
esclavitud francia compensó a los
propietarios de esclavos por las prendas
sufridas y esto es algo que quedó
grabado a fuego en la identidad local y
el caso es que así podríamos seguir con
muchos más ejemplos los problemas
económicos sociales y de pertenencia son
comunes la mayor parte de estos
territorios y la explicación es que la
metrópoli nunca les ha dado alas si
estos territorios hubieran tenido más
libertad y más competencias algunos de
ellos podrían haber explotado la
seguridad jurídica y política que aporta
formar parte de un país como francia
para convertirse en enclaves financieros
turísticos o incluso industrial que es
por ejemplo lo que se ha ocurrido con
muchos territorios británicos de
ultramar desde gibraltar hasta las
bermudas pasando en su día por la
mismísima hong kong
[Música]
asimismo la incapacidad de parís para
enfrentarse a los problemas sociales que
hay en estos lugares como la violencia
la inseguridad o la inmigración ilegal
hace ya tiempo que debería haber
convencido al gobierno francés de que la
descentralización era en estos casos la
mejor y quizás única solución posible no
tiene sentido que estos lugares situados
a miles y miles y miles de kilómetros de
francia dependan de parís prácticamente
para todo y tampoco tiene sentido que
los franceses hayan sustituido la
libertad económica por subsidios y
ayudas públicas pero queridos amigos
amigas hablamos de francia quizás el
país más centralista e intervencionista
de toda la vieja europa que ella es
decir pero llegados hasta aquí la
pregunta es para ti qué crees que
debería hacer francia con todos estos
territorios de ultramar déjanos por aquí
abajo tus respuestas y si este vídeo te
resultó interesante no olvides darle al
botón de like una vez más muchas gracias
por estar ahí un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]